die soldaten sind jetzt im hintergrund
im einsatz sie haben jetzt ihre arbeit
aufgenommen
man sieht es die fahrzeuge haben räumt
schilder vorne angebracht und werden
gleich in das gebiet rhein fahren wo das
ganze ausmaß zu sehen ist und wir gehen
jetzt genau dahin wo die bundeswehr
gleich die arbeit aufnehmen wird das
sind wirklich dramatische bilder also
ich hab es mir gerade mal angeschaut und
das ist wirklich unbeschreiblich die
leute sind in ihren gebäuden
eingeschlossen und kommen nicht raus die
tür ist bis oben hin mit wassermassen
zugedrückt wir schauen uns das ganze mal
an der kameramann folgt mir jetzt die
polizei hatte schon in der
pressekonferenz gesagt dass es in diesen
bereichen auch zu einsatz zur tourismus
kommt und das bestätigt sich auch ganz
immer wieder kommen hier leute
vorgefahren halten an machen fotos von
diesen dramatischen aufnahmen und diese
bilder müssen wir einfach zeigen was
sich hier darbietet er hat sicher
komplette eingangsbereich eines hauses
verabschiedet bäume sind gefallen
es ist hier kein fluss das ist hier ein
ganz normales wohngebiet ein hinterhof
was jetzt mit wassermassen überflutet
ist das wasser wir schauen auch nochmal
einmal gegen das gebäude
das wasser drückt wirklich gegen die
fassade von diesen gebäuden die
situation ist hier wirklich dramatisch
und deshalb ist jetzt die bundeswehr
hier um schnell zu helfen
hinter mir befindet sich eine
riesengroße stahlfirma diese stahlfirma
ist komplett unter wasser
wir sehen aus der firma strömt wasser
unmengen an wasser die firmenfahrzeuge
von dieser firma stehen anhalt meter
unter wasser
und wir sehen einen bereich kameramann
kommt mit mir wo jetzt aktuell ein
feuerwehreinsatz stattfindet auf der
gegenüberliegenden seite von dieser
seite aus kommen wir nicht hin
die straße steht über ein meter unter
wasser die wasserrettung begleitet die
feuerwehr bei solchen einsätzen weil die
gefahr sehr groß ist von dieser strömung
mitgerissen zu werden
aktuell sind fünf leute in diesem haus
eingeschlossen und die feuerwehr
versucht diese menschen jetzt aus den
häusern zu befreien
hinter mir ist das thw im einsatz auch
die sind rund um die uhr im einsatz und
versuchen jetzt wir sehen's wir können
es jetzt eindrucksvoll sehen wie tief
das wasser ist
[Musik]
und auch hier in diesem bereich hinter
dem thw auto sind strömungsretter der
feuerwehr im einsatz
das passiert jetzt eine rettung fünf
personen eingeschlossen in einem haus
die feuerwehr selbst ist hilflos und
deshalb kommen jetzt diese
strömungsretter im einsatz wir versuchen
wir noch näher dran zu gehen um zu
gucken ob wir darauf schauen können für
uns ist es wirklich unmöglich da dran zu
kommen und wir blicken jetzt noch einmal
auf die andere seite zu der firma die
wirklich abgesoffen ist schauen die
ganzen wassermassen die ganzen
wassermassen drücken von allen seiten in
alle richtungen also wirklich
dramatische bilder hier wird jetzt die
bundeswehr die arbeit aufnehmen
das wird wirklich eine harte arbeit
werden alex ist dramatische bilder wir
haben es gerade gesehen das wohngebiet
das aussieht wie ein fließender wie ein
fluss mit starker strömung als würde da
immer einfluss lang gehen so viel wasser
jetzt also unterkommen kann die
bundeswehr an diesen orten momentan
überhaupt irgendetwas tun
oder gibt es jetzt immer nur wieder
vereint sind die orte wo man überhaupt
noch etwas ankommt und andere sachen
muss man jetzt erstmal ihren gang gehen
lassen bis es sich etwas zumindest
wettertechnisch beruhigt wir schauen
hier vor mir das sind geröllmassen die
von oben kommend gegen diese
geröllmassen wird jetzt die bundeswehr
den kampf ansagen und diese geröllmassen
wirklich von der straße befreien
ob das gelingt das ist fraglich aber das
muss man einfach versuchen
ich weiß nicht wo man hier ansetzen kann
um diese wassermassen zu stoppen
aber wir lassen uns überraschen ob sie
die situation über nacht in griff
bekommen
wie viele einsatzkräfte der bundeswehr
sind denn jetzt aktuell in hagen vor ort
um zu helfen vielleicht brauchen sie
auch noch unterstützung aber wer ist
jetzt gerade dann vor allem mit was für
eine gerätschaft ja die bundeswehr ist
wirklich mit schwerem gerät hier die
haben räumt schilder an den fahrzeugen
angebracht um wirklich diese
geröllmassen und bäume die sich kreuz
und quer über die straße laufen in den
griff zu bekommen und zu beseitigen und
25 soldaten sind bisher im einsatz aber
ich denke daran das wird nicht bei
dieser zahl bleiben sondern hier ist
wirklich ordentlich was zu tun so dass
verstärkung hin muss